[Music]
how are you here on the show thank you
how are you I'm doing great you know I
would sing about it today we have very
different gigs I love this job but I'm
here all the time I don't go anywhere
you travel constantly not just shooting
movies but promoting them yes oh you
want a plane all the time all the time
like this is I think week 10 that we've
been going which I can't really complain
because it's kind of great it's great
yeah it's exhausting it is I really
don't know where I am half the time
right well you're here with us now
you're safe you by the ocean yeah the
moon is way too big to be realistic Rio
we did have a super moon recently that's
right that's a couple of weeks ago right
I believe even know what day it is
Thursday it's Thursday yes on planes all
the time play along and what do you do I
don't know everybody today is looks like
they're on their iPads and stuff when I
see them on a plane now they're
listening to music sometimes
occasionally you'll still see a reader I
read you read I read all the time okay
what do you what are you reading these
days
have you read Fifty Shades of Grey you
know what I hear a lot about fifty
Shades of Grey but I don't know much
about it why don't you tell us I got
carded when I bought Fifty Shades of
Grey
I was really I did I was in the airport
and I go to buy it and I and I put this
book up everyone tells me to read this
book so I kinda wanted to do what the
cool kids are doing and use like Hunger
Games and Twilight now it's this and I
put it up there and a girl it's like
chapstick and hand sanitizer in this
book and her girl says to me I need to
see your ID and I was like oh is it is
there something wrong did I know and
she's like no it's for this book and I
mean what am I getting myself into like
why do i why am I getting carded for
reading tradition do you have to be to
read this 15 and you should be 18
because I open it up on the plane I'm
like there's no way I would have my 18
year old child reading this book it is
crazy wild like what's going on in this
book now I must read it
in fact I'm gonna get me a copy now
somebody what's happening in the book
it's well I I was like on a plane
reading it and thank goodness I was in
Seoul I was in South Korea and I'm I'm
reading it so no one can really well I
don't think they can speak English maybe
they could on the plane but they they
look like they I hope they can't because
it's really inappropriate what was in
the book and I'm reading it and my
friend told me to read it it talks about
but clamps like have you ever heard of
that
what yes I haven't finished it yet I
can't continue them like I don't know I
my parents are in the audience
mom I'm sorry but it's it's hot it talks
about what that's for yeah jump-starting
your but if it's an electrical device no
I have no idea I'm just imagining I'm my
friend told me to read it I mean it's
the book the book is about S&M is that
mine I all I've heard is like jokes
about it I have now Andy's read the
narrator of the book and tape
and good join chapter 17
but clamps I haven't read it because it
does you know with the internet and
stuff it is so hard to find dirty stuff
you know that why it just seems silly to
me there's dirty stuff everywhere what's
so dirty about this
I mean all the way I have never heard of
a butt clamp you say that as if when I
haven't heard of something
Andy it's true you've done it all
doesn't and it doesn't it sounds like
more of a functional thing which might
come in handy
necessarily
[Applause]
I'm gonna change the topic just because
I think this is your dad's here I phone
he could Google your dad's googling it
oh my goodness clam calm